- [Mark] All right, Victoria.
Victoria, where are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- I was born in Las Vegas,
but when I was nine I left
and went to Arkansas
and my mom moved out there
and I lived back and forth
between Vegas and Arkansas.
- [Mark] Between your mom and dad?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And how was your childhood?
- I come from a Russian household,
so Russians tend to be really violent.
And there was a lot of physical abuse,
a little bit of sexual abuse.
Some memories I have is
when I was about 13 my uncle shot at me.
And when I was about 16,
my mom fractured my face with
a pipe when she was drunk.
- [Mark] Sounds pretty rough.
- Yeah, I just stuck with that.
- [Mark] What kind of kid
were you in high school?
What kind of kid were you in high school?
- I got into the punk
rock scene pretty early.
So,
my grades were not good.
By the time I was in high school
I was already shooting heroin
and living on the streets.
So, they would send me home
'cause my clothes would be too ripped up.
So I just stopped going.
- [Mark] How far did
you go in high school?
- Sophomore.
But I got my GED later.
- [Mark] Okay.
And where did you go from there?
Living on the street?
- I continued to live on the street,
and then when I was 18 I was
arrested on a big drug bust.
I got raided
and I did some time in jail.
And I got out and I went
to rehab the first time.
And
I had a person in there that I met.
I was always been an artist
and she saw some of my stuff
and she gave me a tattoo kit.
And when I was 18, I started
a tattoo apprenticeship.
And I became a tattoo artist
after two years professionally.
- [Mark] And this was where?
- This was is in LA now.
- [Mark] And so now you're in LA?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And how'd you end
up down here in Skid Row?
- That's kind of fuzzy.
I think I used to have a dealer,
that was more of in Echo Park,
but I lost touch with him.
So,
I knew you come down here
and just ask people for drugs
and they would sell 'em to you.
So I pretty much just did that.
- [Mark] How'd you first
get introduced to heroin?
- I was being physically
abused by my father.
He would choke me and he shot steroids.
And he would choke me
and climb on top of me
and just do weird shit.
And,
I one day
was
in front of a smoke store
and I was under age, I was like 16.
And I was trying to get someone
to buy a pack of smokes.
And this kid did.
And he came back out and
he said, "Do you do black?"
And I just said, "fuck it" in
my head, and I said, "Yeah."
So he took me to his apartment
and he shot me up with
tar and I overdosed.
So then he shot me up with cocaine
to bring me out of it,
'cause this was before Narcan was around.
- [Mark] What are you doing for money now?
- Right now I'm bouncing around.
There was a period, a very
short period of time that
I sold my body, but I just couldn't do it.
It wasn't in me, but boosting mainly.
So.
- [Mark] How much will
you make a day boosting?
- It just depends.
Depends on the security
guards and what's going on.
- [Mark] You've been arrested before?
- Yeah, about 15 times (chukles).
- [Mark] Oh, good.
How long did they hold you for?
- Not long, I always got a word.
Like went on my own regardless since.
- [Mark] So looking at the
situation you're in now,
heroin addict,
just heroin or what are you using now?
- Fentanyl, heroin,
benzos.
And
sometimes I give people
if I'm in like a tent
and people are like either
smoking speed or crack,
and they pass it to me, I'll hit it, but,
I can do without it.
I don't really...
I'm not addicted to it.
- [Mark] But looking
at your situation today
where you're using drugs,
living on the street.
Do you make a connection
with the childhood you had?
The family you grew up in?
(Victoria sighs)
- I really don't know.
'Cause I went to AA for a very long time
and they kind of tell you that like,
you were born with this
disease of addiction
but I think it's a mixture of both.
I think it's hereditary
and your upbringing mixed together.
- [Mark] Yeah. I think that makes sense.
You get depressed sometimes?
- All the time.
- [Mark] Yeah, it's a rough life.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Do you have any friends?
Friends on the street
or like real friends?
- Both.
- [Mark] Both, good for you.
- But I have a couple, I
have two guys that are sober.
Like they have a couple
of years sober in AA
and they've always looked out for me
and made...
Anytime I want to get
sober they helped me.
- [Mark] That's great.
How many years you've
been here on the street
in Skid Row?
- Huh?
- [Mark] How long have
you been here in Skid Row?
- Oh, off and on for 10 years.
- [Mark] How old are you?
- 29.
- [Mark] You're 29?
- Yeah.
I try not to like...
Like I don't have a
tent down here of my own
'cause I don't want to
get stuck down here.
Like I don't want this to become my life.
I want to be a mural
artist and travel the world
and do murals
and continue with my tattoo work.
I'm mostly a graffiti artist.
- [Mark] What's the
worst thing you've seen
since you've been down here for a decade?
Either to you or someone else.
- [Victoria] Let me think about
that 'cause there's a lot.
I've seen a lot.
Ooh, I know what it is.
- [Mark] What is it?
- [Victoria] I was sleeping
in the LA River one night.
And it was Thanksgiving morning.
I woke up, this guy woke me up and,
I can't disclose to you where it is
just because of the
nature of the incident.
But
he asked if I did black.
I said, "Yeah."
And he said, "I sell."
So I was like, "Okay, you
want to sell me some black?"
And he said, "Yeah, just
follow me down to my spot."
He was like,
"Also my family's doing
Thanksgiving dinner morning"
like a morning thing for Thanksgiving.
And he's like, "You can come
eat with us if you want."
He seemed very sincere and nice.
And then we had to cross the river
and we were all stuck in the bushes
and nobody could see us.
And he grabbed me and
he pulled his pants down
and he started pushing my
head down and grabbed my arm
so I couldn't fight back.
And I said, I had a blade up my sleeve.
And I said, "Don't do this.
And I was like, "Seriously,
I'm warning you.
"Don't do this."
And he's like, "No, no,
come on just a little."
And I'm like, "Dude,
please don't do this."
And he's like, "No, no, no, come on."
And he kept pushing me
till finally I was like,
"Okay go ahead I'll do it."
And he let his grip loose a little bit.
And I slid the blade out of my hand
and I stabbed him in the neck
and I had blood up to my
elbows and everywhere.
Then I just ran
and I ran until I started puking
and I couldn't stop puking.
And then I found a gas station
and I put my arms in my shirt
and I went into the bathroom
and washed all the blood off.
- [Mark] Do you know what happened to him?
- Huh?
- And I don't care either.
I mean, I do understand that
most people who are rapists,
do it because they were
probably raped as a child.
So it does make me feel sad
for him because of that fact.
But,
I was,
beaten as a child...
I had child abuse and I don't
do that to other people.
- [Mark] What's the most
important lesson you've learned
in your time on the street?
- Respect.
If you respect people they'll
typically respect you back.
But sometimes especially...
The mess down here,
when the men smoke the mess down here,
they get really horny
and all their inhibitions
go right out the window.
So
do you want me to tell you
that story about yesterday?
- [Mark] Sure.
- So,
this guy I know him from around,
I don't know him super well
but I know him from around.
And he,
I was tired. I was up all night
and I ran into him and he was
like, "Oh, you look tired."
And I was like, "Yeah."
And he said, "Well, I
gotta run some errands.
"You can go crash at the
tent for a couple hours
"if you need to,
"just get rejuvenated."
And
so I did.
And I woke up and he was on top of me
and he pulled my pants
down and spread my legs
and he pulled his pants down
and he was trying to force himself in me.
And I got a hold of a wire over here
and I wrapped around
his neck and pulled it.
And then he kind of started to pass out.
So I kinda got him off of me a little
and I took his knife, which I still have.
And I said, "You have
two options right now.
"You can neither get off of me
or I can fucking stick you."
So, I mean, and don't get
me wrong, I have been raped.
I haven't gotten out
of it every time, but,
it's good.
`I think it sends a good message to women
to say that you can fight back.
You don't have to just let it happen.
You can fight back.
- [Mark] Excellent.
Well, Victoria, thank you
so much for talking with me
and good luck out there.
Stay safe.
- Thank you, I'll try.
Hoover,
he seems like a legit guy.
Like I stayed the night
with him last night.
He didn't even talk about
sex not even one time.
(Mark mumbles)
- Yeah,
he wasn't trying to get nothing out of it.